révolutionner les choses avec le travail
pour fait pour peut-être faire en sorte
qu'on fasse appel à savoir faire qui est
un savoir-faire médical aussi dans un
domaine un peu différent qui est celui
de l'animal mais après tout l'homme
c'est un animal complot
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y va être en partie
reste crédible
à partir du moment où le président bédié
revenir dans la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons plaide une malheureusement on peut
vraiment parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
librement d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de piment nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner cette
élection et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre pour les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation près des yvelines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de guigne ans aujourd'hui une
gauche extrêmement tous les témoins de
notre époque sont dans la grande
interview
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et ne repère faire sur le
terrain tout de suite les grands titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 30
septembre 2001 le couperet est tombé la
fermeture des bars et restaurants à
marseille et aix en provence est
confirmée par la justice
le gouvernement lui prolongé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année le chômage partiel à 100%
pour tous les secteurs protégés
quant au maire et président de métropole
de paris et lyon à lille et grenoble
ils ont rendez-vous demain matin avec
jean castex pour discuter d'éventuelles
adaptations des restrictions avant
l'intervention du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand qui pourrait se solder
par un nouveau tour de vis face au co
vide une explosion des demandes d' aide
alimentaire le secours populaire alerte
sur une augmentation de la précarité
pendant les deux mois de confinement
près de 1 million 300 mille personnes se
sont ainsi rendus dans ses permanences
contre 3 millions 300 mille sur toute
l'année 2019
près de la moitié d'entre elles était
jusqu'ici inconnu de l'association selon
le dernier baromètre publié aujourd'hui
[Musique]
après emmanuel macron song et la merkel
qui annonce qu'elle va rencontrer
prochainement la chef de l'opposition en
biélorussie svetlana tirano sky a une
légitimité de l'opposition renforcée par
le président français il souhaite
maintenir le dialogue entre l'europe et
la russie de vladimir poutine comme il
l'a rappelé lors de sa tournée
diplomatique dans les et à malte
[Musique]
un règlement de comptes à ok corral ou
plutôt à cleveland pour le premier débat
télévisé de la présidentielle américaine
donald trump et joe biden ont échangé
railleries invectivé attaques
personnelles à des débats houleux sans
aborder les questions de fond entre le
président républicain et son rival
démocrate à un peu plus d'un mois du
scrutin
[Musique]
et on débute avec la situation sanitaire
en france et les derniers chiffres de
santé publique france l'agent s'annonce
plus de 12000 nouvelles contaminations
aux colis de 19 ans 24 heures soixante
quatre personnes sont décédées à
l'hôpital et 826 patients sont
actuellement en réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests se situe
lui à 7,6 pour cent et dans ce contexte
le premier ministre va recevoir demain
matin les maires de plusieurs grandes
villes l'objectif affiché améliorer la
concertation dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie coronavirus elle les
représentants des villes de paris lyon
lille et grenoble ont rendez vous chacun
leur tour pour discuter d'éventuelles
adaptations des mesures de restriction
en raison de l'épidémie
l exécutif veut répondre au procès
instruit la semaine passée par les élus
marseillais
vent debout on se souvient contre la
décision de fermer bars et restaurants
dans la métropole
aix marseille il avait dénoncé les
décisions unilatérales du gouvernement
et crier au manque de concertation reçus
par jean castex françois baroin
président de l'association des maires de
france a rappelé la nécessité de ces
concertations donc le sujet de plus
grande ampleur que ce qu'on a lu à vivre
avant l'été et donc il est absolument
nécessaire et indispensable pour la
bonne tenue et afin de rassurer la
population que les maires soient tous
premiers rangs de la transmission
d'informations de ce qu'ils constatent
qu'ils soient aussi les premiers relais
de positions prises par le gouvernement
que nous pouvons comprendre mais que
nous ne saurions accepter si la
concertation telle qu'elle avait été
conçue la semaine dernière père du rsa
ne semble pas être le 15
cet échange d'aujourd'hui va dans une
direction qui est meilleur un des élus
est libre de choisir les restrictions
adapté à leur territoire mais un état
qui peut prendre le relais à tout moment
pour revenir sur la relation entre les
maires et le gouvernement face aux
mesures est liée à la crise sanitaire
nous a rejoint
jean-philippe du
- clément vice-président de la région
ile-de-france mère udi de mennecy dans
l'essonne
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors depuis le début nous
nous appuyons sur le couple maire préfet
a martelé jean castex jusque là il est
vrai que le gouvernement communique
beaucoup sur sa volonté de s'appuyer sur
les territoires pour faire face à la
crise sanitaire pour autant sur le
terrain s noka jean philippe dugoin
clément bonsoir oui on a je crois
beaucoup de progrès à faire en termes de
concertation et de travail en commun
alors ce qui est vrai c'est l'état était
confronté à un problème inédit qui
n'avait jamais eu lieu dans l'histoire
moderne
mais on a été l'objet sur toute la
première phase du coc vide d'un certain
nombre de décisions pas forcément
rationnelle au niveau local d'un
territoire à l'autre parce que décidé
depuis le sommet de l'état on a eu la
semaine dernière ses prises de décisions
qui ont été faites sans aucune
concertation avec les collectivités et
je crois que si on n'arrive pas à
retisser ce lien on n'en sortira pas on
est dans une période d'anxiété de peur
pour beaucoup de gens d'énervement et de
colère pour d'autres et si on n'est pas
capable d'avoir des institutions qu'ils
fassent front commun et bien on laisse
un doute et là où il ya un doute et bien
on nourrit les peurs en nourrit les
inquiétudes et le seul moyen de faire
front commun c'est d'être sur des
décisions partagées
non pas qu'ils soient imposées d'en haut
en expliquant la veille au soir d'un
point presse ce qui est fait en appelant
les maires le lendemain matin
mais en travaillant mérite ablement pour
adapter les solutions à chaque
territoire et encore une fois la réalité
du territoire des mini drones ce n'est
pas celui de paris intra muros qui n'est
pas forcément celui du reste de l'île de
france mais finalement qu'est ce qui
coince selon vous dans la communication
entre les haies
de terrain et le gouvernement sait qu'il
y en a extrêmement peu en fin de
l'excision entre la communication entre
les élus de terrain au gouvernement
c'est les prises de décisions parfois
extrêmement abrupte sur le fait de dire
du jour au lendemain on ferme les
marchés alors qu'on laisse les grandes
surfaces ou vers le dire on interdit le
la course à pied dans certains
territoires sans avoir concerté les élus
et derrière on revient en arrière
c'est vraiment des décisions qui sont
prises avec une envie de bien faire face
à une urgence
ce qui est évident mais qui sont prises
par le gouvernement sans aucune
concertation
et quand on parle de décentralisation la
décentralisation c'est à donner un rôle
une responsabilité un pouvoir aux élus
locaux
c'est pas faire en sorte que les élus
locaux soient des exécuteurs de l'état
ça c'est des fonctionnaires c'est la
déconcentration c'est ce que font les
structures déconcentrées de l'état dans
les territoires et je pense qu'on est
dans un pays qui après plus de 200 ans
de démocratie ne sait toujours pas ce
qu'est la véritable décentralisation
alors on en parlait à l'instant on n'a
entendu dans la semaine dernière la
colère des élus de la région de
marseille et d'aix dénonçant un manque
de concertation justement avec les élus
locaux
quant à la fermeture des bars et
restaurants avec la réunion de demain
entre les maires des grandes villes et
le premier ministre est ce que le
gouvernement veut rectifier le tir selon
vous je pense que symboliquement ils
sont rendu compte qu'il était allé trop
loin que ça avait été maladroit que il y
avait eu une césure extrêmement forte
qui est en train de se créer ça y est on
est dans le pays développés où il ya le
plus fort taux de doute de rejet de
méfiance de la population par rapport à
son gouvernement sur la gestion de la
fpt l'escaut vide et donc ils sont
rendus compte qu effectivement enfin
d'avoir une sorte de rétropédalage donc
symboliquement on fait venir un certain
nombre de responsables la réalité c'est
que la déclinaison de mesures pour le
candidat ne peut se faire que territoire
par territoire et elle ne se fera pas
depuis un ministère avec des
représentants nationaux mais elle se
fera région par région avec les
représentants régionaux département par
département et quasiment ville par ville
vraiment la réalité de ce qu'on a en
normandie n'est pas celle du grand test
les mesures à prendre la justification
des mesures l'acceptabilité des mesures
ne sont pas les mêmes d'un territoire à
l'autre et on a véritablement but sur la
première phase du comique avec des raies
le très générale malgré tout est alors
qu'il y avait des différences y est
question territoriale y compris par
rapport à la preuve à la progression des
maladies extrêmement diverses
alors demain matin les maires seront
accompagnés pour ces réunion des
directeurs généraux des agences
régionales de santé ainsi que des
préfets de département jean castex comme
il l'a fait mardi à l'assemblée arrêtée
a répété l'importance à ses yeux du
couple maires préfets indispensable pour
reprendre des mesures adaptées est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les infos elle circule
bien entre les différents acteurs de
terrain et les préfectures ou encore les
agences régionales de santé sur les
agences régionales de santé ça ne dépend
véritablement d'une agence à l'autre
ça dépend d'une région à l'autre il ya
des régions où il ya eu de très bonne
coopération de très bon fonctionnement
d'autres c'est extrêmement compliqué
donc vraiment on est sur du calot cas
sur la question de l'organisation des du
couple préfet mais roux maire préfet
globalement ça fonctionne bien la
réalité ces cas c'est souvent les
préfets qui sont la courroie de
transmission de l'état au niveau
parisien ont pu avoir des décisions
appliquées qu'il n'était pas forcément
rationnelle par rapport aux territoires
locaux et ou ceux où ils se sont
eux-mêmes retrouver à savoir comment
essayer d'atténuer la portée d'une
mesure trop générale ou d'en adapter
je reprends la question de la fermeture
des marchés où on a empêché une
profession de travail et une profession
alimentaire alors que dans le même temps
ont laissé ouvert les supermarchés
beaucoup de préfet on trouvera ont
trouvé ont cherché comment essayer
d'adapter une mesure qui était beaucoup
trop rigide
le problème c'est que ça l'idée semaine
pour pouvoir se faire et qu'en fonction
de l'appréciation de chaque préfet on a
pu avoir des disparités assez forte d'un
département à l'autre mais ça veut dire
que les préfets eux mêmes ont du mal à
faire comprendre la situation leur
terrain aux membres du gouvernement les
préfets vous savez ils sont pris entre
le marteau et l'enclume d'un côté ils
ont des locaux qui disent on connaît
d'autres territoires voilà les sujets
condal puis l'autre ils ont deux
directives nationales et quand vous êtes
préfet vous êtes aussi nommé par l'état
vous êtes en situation de devoir rendre
des comptes à l'état quand vous êtes
maire ou élu local vous devez rendre des
comptes à vos électeurs la légitimité et
la responsable
il n'est pas dans la même personne en
tout cas est ce que c'est une bonne
chose que les élus restent libres de
choisir les restrictions adapté à leur
territoire est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode ça va dans le bon sens tout ce
qui va vers un renforcement des pouvoirs
locaux et avec une bonne chose et à
l'amitié aussi transférer une part de
responsabilité parce que moi je
considère qu'il faut aussi que les élus
aient le courage d'assumer ou pas les
décisions qu'ils sont en situation de
devoir prendre parce qu'il peut aussi
avoir des fois des postures vous savez
en politique il ya beaucoup de gens qui
font dans la posture qui peuvent être
assez caricatural au et c'est facile de
dire c'est scandaleux les tâches et où
l'état n'a pas fait ou l'état aurait dû
faire je pense que renvoyer la balle
donnée une quote part de responsabilité
aux élus
c'est aussi une bonne chose et c'est on
est dans un pays une république salue
aussi est une république de la
responsabilité
ce sentiment est il partagé par la
majorité des maires de france c'est à
dire ces injonctions dans l'eau est ce
qu'elles ont de plus en plus de mal à
passer pour tous les maires de france
mais je pense qu'elles ont de plus en
plus de mal à passer non seulement pour
les mères mais aussi pour les citoyens
pour les citoyens effectivement vous
vous rendez compte vous sur le terrain
que c'est compliqué de faire appliquer
toutes ces mesures quel retour vous avez
de vos administrés
ce qui est très compliqué c'est bien
souvent qui a pas forcément de cohérence
quand vous dites on interdit aux monts
ferme des cafés on n'interdit pas les
laits les soirées privées qui de toute
façon lieu on n'interdit pas les flux
dans les transports qui sont absolument
colossaux
on a énormément de choses on n'est pas
forcément sur une cohérence parfaite
on est sur un pays où je trouve les gens
sont à cran les gens ont vécu deux mois
de confinement vécu une période de
confinement difficiles ont créé une
certaine manière pendant l'été être
sortie de la crise que l'on allait
pouvoir repartir à autre chose et
aujourd'hui quand je sens vraiment une
agressivité une défiance comme j'en ai
rarement vécu comme j'en ai rarement
senti auprès d'eux
de beaucoup de français et pour terminer
en tant qu'élu local est ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être en première
ligne
seul et sans réels moyens aujourd'hui en
première ligne oui seul nom parce que
élu local vous n'êtes jamais seul format
conseillers municipaux on est un groupe
et une collectivité d'élus moi j'ai la
chance dans mon département d'avoir une
structure préfectoral qui est allé coude
qui est efficiente
après ça dépend énormément de relations
interpersonnelles mais en tout cas en
essonne on a cette chance là mais en
première ligne wii et concernant les
moyens de toute façon ça fait dix ans
que l'état a assuré ses marges
budgétaires sur les collectivités
locales et le bloc communal en
particulier donc oui les moyens
aujourd'hui ils sont de plus en plus
faible merci beaucoup jean philippe
dugoin clément d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france mais rudy de mennecy une
commune dans l'essonne et la colère est
grande chez les restaurateurs et les
patrons de bar est l'un d'entre eux dans
la commune de fourmies dans le
département du nord a entamé une grève
de la faim il s'est vu fermer son
établissement pour deux mois pour non
respect des règles sanitaires liés aux
qu'ovide 19 et débordements répétés
enchaîné devant la sous-préfecture
d'avesnes-sur-helpe il dénonce une
justice de copinage et une affaire
politique bassem chab y est cynthia
lauvergeon sont allés à sa rencontre
comme chaque jour depuis plus de deux
semaines s'est assis sur sa chaise que
sylvain redou poursuit sa grève de la
faim sur le trottoir de la
sous-préfecture d'avesnes-sur-helpe dans
le département du nord
le patron de bar demandent justice après
la fermeture administrative de son
établissement
deux mois de fermeture pour port
irrégulier du masque de clients mais
également pour des bagarres à proximité
de son bar il dénonce un acharnement des
pouvoirs publics et une justice de
copinage aujourd'hui on sanctionne pas
ceux qui se battent
on sanctionne le patron de
l'établissement alors si les forces de
l'ordre arrivent au moment d'une bagarre
je pense que ces puces à eux de
sanctionner ce qu'ils ont mis le
désordre parce que c'est pas le patron
kamil désordre ouais je me révolte je me
révolte parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
plus au temps des rois
les élus qui sont à la disposition de la
population des commerçants et des
artisans et des chefs d'entreprise cette
fermeture est ému un grand nombre
d'habitués d'anonymes qui ont apporté
leur soutien à travers une pétition
lancée sur les réseaux sociaux
parmi ses premiers soutiens karine sa
compagne quand elle n'est pas auprès de
lui elle s'occupe tant bien que mal de
son bar vidé de ses clients au delà de
l'incompréhension elle a aujourd'hui
peur pour la santé de son patron
bah il est faible donc c'est il arrive à
son 17e jour de grève de la faim où il
n'a pas mangé du tout là il a du mal
il commence à avoir un peu de mal à
boire donc j'essaye d'être plus possible
avec lui n'ont pas le laisser seul
on n'est pas à l'abri de quoi que ce
soit mais ne veut pas lâcher
mais voilà côté administration cette
décision semble bel et bien justifié à
la sous-préfecture d'avesnes-sur-helpe
la grève de la faim du patron de bar
n'est pas passée inaperçue concernant
cette grève de la faim je tiens tout
d'abord à dire que on a une attention
particulière par rapport à cette
situation sa chaleur et que à ma demande
les sapeurs pompiers viennent
régulièrement pour pouvoir vérifier les
taxes antennes monsieur recloux à
l'origine de cette décision
administrative
le service public se justifie l'arrêté
de fermeture administrative qui a été
pris a été motivée par un certain nombre
d'éléments
tout d'abord les services de la
gendarmerie ou constaté plusieurs
altercations et bagarres devant cet
établissement et ils ont également pu
relever la non distanciation sociale et
surtout le non respect des mesures
sanitaires et en l'occurrence le port du
masque à la mairie de fourmies l'after
est connue de tous un lieu décrit comme
convivial qui constitue néanmoins des
troubles à l'ordre public et ce de
manière répétée la sous préfecture a
proposé deux mois de fermeture
administrative
moi je suis intervenu auprès du
sous-préfet de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent mieux rue cloud s'expliquer de
vive voix ce qui a été fait puisque il a
été reçu par la secrétaire général tout
début août
ça avait relativement modifier les
choses puisque le sous préfet proposé à
l'époque 15 jours de fermeture
administrative
sauf contre le 15 août et le 15
septembre il semble qu'il y a eu quatre
à cinq interventions des gendarmes
ce qui fait que le bas du coup il s'est
pris deux mois déterminé à aller
jusqu'au bout de son combat
sylvain roux dénonce un ras-le-bol
général et des conditions de travail
devenues insupportables pour les
commerçants et chefs d'entreprise de sa
région je lâcherai pas parce que vous
faites c'est mon barrymore j'aurais
mourir avec l'administration française
on ne peut pas tu as peut pas se
permettre de prendre la décision de la
continuité de la pérennité du bar on
peut plus continuer comme ça les
français en ont marre
les françaises en ont marre les gens qui
travaillent en ont ras-le-bol face à
cette décision silvert redoux a déposé
un recours débouté par le tribunal
administratif d'affaires doit
prochainement être jugée sur le fond
dernier rempart pour éviter la faillite
et autres conséquences inquiétantes de
cette crise sanitaire
elle a fait basculer de nombreux
français dans la précarité alimentaire
celle alerte du secours populaire à qui
publie son nouveau baromètre de la
pauvreté pendant les deux mois de
confinement près d'un million trois cent
mille personnes se sont rendues dans ses
permanences sur l'ensemble de l'année
2010 9,3 millions 300 mille personnes
ont sollicité l'aide du secours
populaire et cette tendance devrait
perdurer selon l'association pour en
parler nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes alexis poulain bonsoir
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors le chômage partiel a beau
avoir été largement déployées durant le
confinement
les conséquences économiques se font
donc ressentir dans les foyers français
qui sont ces français qui aujourd'hui
ont basculé dans la précarité bien ce
sont ceux qui attendaient une
pérennisation de leur emploi en cdi ce
qui était en cdd qui pensait dans la
restauration notamment pouvoir avoir
plus d'emplois ceux qui attendaient que
l'économie reprenne et ce n'est pas le
cas et donc vivre aujourd'hui avec un
smic
et bien c'est difficile c'est même de
l'avis de la plupart des le français
sous le seuil de pauvreté vous dire
combien c'est difficile de finir le mois
et encore pire quand vous êtes au rsa et
que vous êtes mère célibataire ou père
célibataire et que vous devez élever vos
enfants
les gens souffrent aujourd'hui la
réalité c'est que beaucoup de français
plus d'un sur deux ont peur de tomber
dans la précarité c'est l alerte
important il y a deux ans des gilet
jaune qui voyait bien là où on voulait
ans
née la plupart de la population
française vers davantage de
paupérisation parce que c'est politique
mise en place depuis 2010 est et même un
peu avant et bien n'ont fait que creuser
les inégalités et qu'il faudrait l'avis
de beaucoup et bien enlever les
solidarités et c'est pas le cas et c'est
dangereux parce que à partir du moment
où vous perdez votre emploi à et bien
c'est le risque de perdre votre logement
et de vous retrouver à la rue sans rien
c'est à dire c'est une précarisation
grandissante et cette peur là elle est
présente davantage depuis 2007 ce
sentiment de précarisation n'a fait
qu'augmenter dans la population
française
rien n'a été fait pour bien y remédier
on l'a appris cette à plan de relance
alors bruno le maire est très fier
allez-y nation un plan de relance par
exemple vous avez plusieurs milliards
qui sont mis bien sûr pour essayer de
sauver les entreprises à maximum et tant
mieux parce que les entreprises créent
l'emploi mais sur la pauvreté sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté la précarité
seulement 200 millions d'euros ce n'est
pas à la hauteur on est loin du compte
aujourd'hui on voit bien que la pauvreté
la lutte contre la pauvreté n'existe pas
dans la tête des responsables politiques
et c'est aux associations est bien de
faire ce qu'elles peuvent pour sauver
des gens de la famine pour sauver des
gens de la rue et parfois ce n'est pas
suffisant on l'a appris cet après midi
le dispositif de chômage partiel à 100%
est maintenue jusqu'à la fin de l'année
pour tous les secteurs protégés et non
pour le seul secteur de l'hôtellerie
restauration
ce type de mesure est ce que ça va être
suffisant selon vous non ce type de
mesure est nécessaire évidemment
aujourd'hui compte tenu du choix du
gouvernement de fermer les commerces les
bars les temps en d'autres 1 donc il va
falloir aider ces secteurs qui sont
sinistrées et pour longtemps l'aérien le
transport donc le chômage partiel c'est
une bonne chose
jusqu'à la fin de l'année on peut se
demander pourquoi et que va-t-il se
passer après est ce que la croissance va
revenir à ce que la reprise est préparée
annoncé est ce que les emplois vont
pouvoir reprendre regarder autour de
nous c'est plan social après plan social
que ce soit dans l'industrie dans le
transport les petits commerces qui met
la clé sous la porte
les fleuristes qui ferment on a les
chiffres maintenant qu'il commence à
arriver et donc ce chômage partiel
jusqu'à la fin de l'année c'est un peu
pour essayer d'amortir la chute qui va
être terrible mais les gens ne sont pas
dupes ils craignent évidemment pour
l'avenir parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
perspective
et je ne vois pas la perspective est là
ce n'est pas que le fait du gouvernement
français dans la reprise de l'économie
mondiale après ce blocage complet par le
virus
donc il faudrait au delà du chômage
partiel penser à ceux qui vont qui
risque de tomber dans l'extrême
précarité et qui ne peuvent pas dépendre
simplement des associations ou bien de
la générosité des gens parce que le
secours populaire se féliciter que 5000
personnes soient bénévoles soit des
nouveaux volontaires qui rejoignent
leurs rangs mais ce n'est pas ça qui va
faire qu'on va éviter que de nombreuses
familles se retrouvent à la rue il va
falloir un plan en un plan pour l'hiver
un plan pour saisir des logements vides
pour faire en sorte que on évite la rue
à de nombreuses familles et puis pour
que en attendant que l'économie reprenne
eh bien ces gens là ne meurent pas de
faim et on peut le faire parce qu'on a
les moyens on a la chance d'être dans
une économie développée en france et en
europe
or malheureusement nos politiques sont
obsédés par la croissance par sauver les
entreprises
il faut aussi penser aux humains à ceux
qui souffrent au quotidien qu'ils sont
obligés de se priver de repas qui saute
beaucoup de repasser dans son rapport du
secours populaire qui et qui
malheureusement n'ont pas d'autre choix
que ces associations pour éviter la mort
par famine tout simplement
derrière cette précarité également
alexis poulain les enfants le secours
populaire craint notamment que les
familles soient en incapacité par
exemple de payer la cantine comme en
face à cela faut-il réagir selon vous
oui alors il y à aussi au sein de ce
sondage les gens qui répondent et qui
ont peur parce qu'ils ont vu le
décrochage scolaire ils n'ont vécu c'est
à dire que quand l'école a fermé on a
pensé qu'il y aura une continuité
pédagogique un de manière dématérialisée
avec les ordinateurs avec internet
or pour des familles au rsa pour
beaucoup de familles il n'y a tout
simplement pas d'équipement informatique
il n'y a pas de connexion à internet il
ya donc des enfants
sont sortis du système scolaire et
beaucoup de familles qui ont peur en
fait d'un déclassement parce que leurs
enfants n'ont pas pu rattraper ce temps
perdu du confinement et là encore je ne
sais pas ce qu'a prévu jean michel
bancaire pour ces enfants là quelques
elle va être elles vont être les mesures
qui vont permettre justement de dd à
rattraper et surtout assure une
continuité pédagogique pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de matériel
or même s'il ya eu des promesses en
disant que si jamais il fallait confiné
il y aurait des ordinateurs on attend
les preuves
on attend de voir où sont ses
ordinateurs est ce qu'on va pouvoir
équiper des familles qui en auraient
besoin notamment pour leurs enfants pour
éviter
et bien qu'on creuse encore davantage
des inégalités et qu'on se retrouve bien
dans un apartheid social ou les très
riches vivent très bien malgré la crise
et où les très pauvres rentrer dans un
monde qui est celui des biens de la peur
du lendemain et du risque de famine
alors pour conclure vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure les gilets jaunes on se souvient
de cet élan de cohésion au début du
mouvement notamment sur les ronds points
est ce que ce type d lent pourrait à
nouveau venir secouer l'exécutif dans
les semaines et mois à venir
la mobilisation elle existe comme je le
disais 5000 volontaires de plus les gens
sont solidaires
beaucoup de françaises se rend compte
qu'ils doivent faire quelque chose pour
aider leur prochain
le problème c'est au niveau des palais
de la république où on vit bien on mange
bien on est sous les dorures et où
finalement on parle davantage aux
financiers internationaux aux donneurs
d'ordres aux grands patrons et qu'on ne
voit pas la réalité c'est ce qu'on
appelle la solitude du pouvoir alors
emmanuel macron a pourtant fait des
maraudes il a vu ce qu'était la pauvreté
dans la rue mais au delà de la mise en
scène pour prendre des photographies
qu'est ce qu'il a appris qu'est ce qu'il
va se passer derrière qu'elle va être
quelles vont être les moyens donnés à
ces associations et au delà de 5 et que
va faire l'état pour éviter l'extrême
pauvreté parce qu'encore une fois la
pauvreté est un choix politique et que
fait le gouvernement aujourd'hui
eh bien il veut continuer sur la réforme
des retraites continue et sur la réforme
de l'assurance chômage qui vont me faire
qu'accélérer la précarisation de
nombreux de france
c'est donc c'est un non sens ou bien
c'est un choix et si c'est ce choix là
qui est fait et bien c'est le choix de
la pauvreté et le gouvernement devra
l'assumer
merci beaucoup alexis poulain
appel que vous êtes éditorialistes et
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la biélorussie après sa rencontre avec
emmanuel macron la chef de file de
l'opposition tigran of sky à doit
rencontrer prochainement
la chancelière allemande angela merkel
et puis direction les états unis le
premier débat télévisé entre donald
trump et joe biden s'est transformée en
règlement de compte entre les deux
candidats sans réel la discussion sur
les sujets de fond rester avec nous sur
rt france a tout de suite
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes aéro pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire les
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on voit bien en 37 cantona
un degré de plus de 38 en médecine à une
fabrique une petite fièvre gouffre
quelque chose la plage est l année là
aujourd'hui chacun dans ses activités
impact la nature impacter notre les
questions environnementales
le risque c'est évidemment le
réchauffement climatique
mais l'autre risque c'est aussi la
réduction de l'activité économique jean
jaurès disait d'une phrase que j'aime
beaucoup aller à l'idéal
tout en comprenant le réel
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
dans les bancs où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs a
certes chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement dumont discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois voyez des images assez
touchants de l'armée qui était presque
impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause d un politique et sont en
train de manipuler l'armée on sait très
bien pourquoi ils nous tirent dessus
c'est pas s'ils savent que c'est leur
fin ils se préparent le seul langage
qu'ils connaissaient la violence il ne
va pas être violent mais on va rester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française
emmanuel macron a donc terminé ce soir
sa première visite diplomatique dans les
pays baltes
il a rencontré ce matin le premier
ministre letton au coeur des discussions
de nombreux dossiers dont la crise en
biélorussie la situation au karabagh et
les relations avec la russie dans le
président français a insisté sur la
nécessité pour les européens de discuter
avec moscou malgré des désaccords
écoutez le l'agenda de discussion est un
agenda très large qui doit aller des
sujets défensif au sujet offensif mais
qui consiste à voir quel est le chemin
qui nous permettra d'aller vers une
forme de normalisation de nos relations
avec la russie parce que nous partageons
le même espace nous avons des sujets sur
lesquels nous pouvons travailler avec la
russie ce qui se passe au nord par
exemple au nord karabagh est un bon
sujet la russie les états unis et la
france font partie de ce qu'on appelle
le groupe de minsk nous sommes censés
travailler ensemble et si nous
n'engageons pas la russie ne régleront
pas tous ces conflits régionaux
et puis nous avons les sujets d'avenir
où la question est posée aux russes de
savoir s'ils veulent travailler avec
nous et comment et puis nous avons notre
sécurité collective qui impose compte
tenu notre géographie d'avoir une
discussion avec les russes on ne réglera
jamais le sujet du désarmement et de la
protection du sol européen sans avoir
une discussion avec la russie et par
ailleurs emmanuel macron indiqué qu'il
aurait un entretien ce soir avec son
homologue russe vladimir poutine
et avec le président américain donald
trump avant de rendre compte de la
situation devant le conseil européen
et puis après emmanuel macron ces
anglais la merkel qui s'apprête à
rencontrer svetlana tirano sky à la chef
d'opposition biélorusses dont elle
admire à l'abnégation écoutez je vais
bientôt rencontrer la leader de
l'opposition madame tirano scalia quand
on voit le courage des femmes qui vont
dans la rue pour protester contre la
corruption
je ne peux pas dire que je trouve cela
vraiment impression le conflit
biélorusse au coeur des discussions du
président français durant sa tournée
dans les états baltes pour en parler
nous sommes avec l'autre blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales que
blanchemaison bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
pourquoi la chancelière allemande angela
merkel souhaite elle aussi rencontrer
l'opposante biélorusse svetlana tirano
sky a il ya plusieurs raisons la
première est une raison un peu personnel
ces thématiques 1 austral air est
maintenant une sorte d'icône de la
liberté en europe et madame merkel est
la femme qui a l'a le plus de pouvoir en
europe et peut-être même dans le monde
donc elle souhaite la rencontrer elle
l'a dit à la tribune du bundestag pour
la cause des femmes également le
deuxième motif il est politique
intérieure c'est que le parlement
allemand est là et là et l'opinion
publique allemande souhaite que cette
rencontre ait lieu
le troisième c'est sans doute la
compétition amicale avec emmanuel macron
puisque emmanuel macron la rencontrait
hier la chancelière est d'autant plus
anxieuse delà de la rencontrer
rapidement
et puis enfin l'allemagne exerce
actuellement la présidence tournante de
l'union européenne
et comme vous l'avait dit il ya un
conseil européen qui commence demain
après-midi et donc madame merkel veut
avoir discuté avec cette lan à tikhonov
callas pour pouvoir faire décidé le
conseil européen sur ce qu'il convient
de faire pour faciliter une transition
en biélorussie alors sur le dossier de
tikhonov gaillard est invité rieur alors
si on le dossier biélorusse justement
emmanuel macron tout comme la
chancelière allemande d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron peut-il maintenir le
log avec vladimir poutine qui protège
lui minsk
oui je crois que oui en partant des
réalités la première réalité c'est que
le bélarus la biélorussie est solidement
arrimés à la russie d'abord parce que la
russie et son principal partenaire
économique et de très loin
ensuite parce que la biélorussie fait
partie de l'union économique
eurasiatique avec la russie et le
kazakhstan et ensuite parce que la
biélorussie est partenaire avec la
russie dans l'organisation du traité de
sécurité de coopération qui est une
sorte d'alliance politico-militaire qui
lie les deux pays donc indépendamment
même de la personne de monsieur le catch
enhco la biélorussie est arrimée à la
russie alors évidemment l'astuce de
monsieur le catch enhco et de faire
valoir à moscou que tout ça ne tient
qu'à lui que si lui s'effaçait et bien
tous ses liens avec la russie risquerait
de se déliter
ce qui est faux ce qu'il faut et
d'ailleurs les manifestants qui sont
dans la rue tous les week-ends à minsk à
minsk et dans les autres villes de
biélorussie disent qu'ils veulent garder
des liens très étroits avec la russie et
qu'il n'est pas question de se
rapprocher de l'otan ou d'autres
organisations de l'ouest par conséquent
arrimage de la biélorussie à la russie
en effet le dialogue et et doit exister
il existe avec la russie le président
maquereau et le présent poutine se sont
élevées se sont téléphoné au moins cinq
fois depuis le mois d'août
ils vont scruter les faux nez ce soir et
il parle de beaucoup de sujets il faut
élargir le sujet il n'y a pas que la
biélorussie il ya également les gorny
karabakh bien sûr mais il ya aussi la
discussion sur laquelle ils se sont mis
d'accord il y a un an
lorsqu'ils se sont vus à brégançon sur
l' architecture de confiance et de
sécurité en europe
ce qu'il convient de faire pour
restaurer la confiance en europe et pour
avoir une architecture de sécurité qui
soit fiable
celle-ci englobe naturellement tous les
conflits gelés alors médiation
internationale comme cela était proposé
ou sanction qu'est ce qui peut faire
bouger les choses
aujourd'hui sur le dossier biélorusse
alors les sanctions il y en a déjà
puisque le royaume uni grande bretagne a
pris hier des sanctions le canada aussi
ce sont des sanctions ciblées qui vise
monsieur loukachenko et quelques-uns de
ses proches responsables de la
répression policière
cette courbe purement symbolique puisque
ces sanctions leur interdisent l'accès à
des visas et leur interdisent aussi
d'avoir des comptes bancaires dans les
pays qui prennent les sanctions
il est probable que le conseil européen
prendra des sanctions du même type d'ici
vendredi soir et ceux ci aura aussi une
valeur symbolique
c'est important pour marquer le soutien
à la population gay le russe mais ça n'a
pas de conséquence pratique puisque bien
entendu les comptes bancaires des
dirigeants biélorusses sont partis
beaucoup plus loin en asie depuis bien
longtemps et qui n'ont probablement pas
l'intention de passer leurs vacances
dans des pays de l'union européenne donc
c'est symbolique mais c'est important
c'est important et pour ce qui est de la
médiation il ya une sorte de consensus
pour dire que l'organisation de sécurité
de coopération en europe doit jouer un
rôle là le bélarus et la russie en font
partie et la difficulté c'est en effet
que monsieur loukachenko ne veut pas en
entendre parler
en réalité monsieur le coach échos veut
garder l'intégralité du pouvoir pour lui
veut rester dans ce statut particulier
de la biélorussie où l'économie n'a pas
évolué depuis 26 ans que monsieur le cas
de cheikh lô est au pouvoir c'est une
économie où l'état contrôle à peu près
75 % du pnb
c'est une économie qui reste de type soc
des eaux soviétique
c'est un conservatoire néo soviétique
donc effectivement il faudra bien que
tout ça évolue un jour alors
bien sûr monsieur poutine ne peut pas le
bousculer puisque monsieur le catch est
qu exerce une sorte de chantage sur
moscou et qu'il n'y a pas de solution de
rechange dans l'immédiat mais il faudra
bien retrouver une un jour et fait
reculer pour mieux sauter merci beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre
expertise rappelle que vous êtes expert
en relations internationales
la russie propose d'accueillir des
pourparlers arménie azerbaïdjan au
quatrième jour de conflit armé entre ces
deux pays du caucase qui se disputent le
territoire du haut karabagh moscou qui
on vient de l'apprendre affirme que des
combattants de groupes armés illégaux
notamment de syrie et de libye sont en
train d'être déployés dans la zone de
conflit
une accusations déjà formulées par
l'arménie contre la turquie et
l'azerbaïdjan qui dément l'onu elle
appelle à l'arrêt immédiat des combats
il ya une reprise sans par des
négociations constructives ce que le
premier ministre arménien nikol
pashinian juge louis je cite inapproprié
alors que les combats sont en cours
l'azerbaïdjan de son côté promet de
poursuivre sa campagne militaire
légitime
grégoire doucet
les canon tonne toujours dans le caucase
du sud depuis ce dimanche les forces
azéries sont aux prises avec l'armée de
la république d'artsakh dans le
haut-karabagh une région séparatiste de
l'azerbaïdjan soutenus par l'arménie
voisine
bakou et erevan s'accusent d'avoir lancé
l'offensive et se rejettent la
responsabilité de la reprise des
hostilités lundi
l'arménie a d'ailleurs saisi la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
demander des mesures provisoires
d'urgence contre l'azerbaïdjan des
interférences extérieures qui ont été
dénoncés par les autorités de l'artsakh
et des revan elle accuse la turquie
d'ingérence affirmant qu'un de ses
avions militaires et son pilote aurait
été abattu par un f-16 turcs armés
l'arménie et les arméniens du haut
karabagh sont désormais exposée à une
menace directe de la part de la turquie
selon nos données
la turquie cherche un prétexte pour
intervenir de façon encore plus large
dans ce conflit un détail très important
consiste à ce que la turquie est de fait
un piqué dans ce processus
selon nos informations authentifier des
instructeurs militaires et des hauts
gradés sont actuellement présents dans
les centres de commandement azéri il
dirige même parfois des opérations
militaires la turquie a toutefois
démenti l'annoncé arménienne et le
président azéri le martèle ankara ne
participent pas aux combats
nous ne possédons pas d'information à ce
sujet je viens tout juste d'apprendre
une telle nouvelle est apparue dans le
champ médiatique
il n'y a aucune confirmation à cela les
chasseurs f 16 de l'armée de l'air
turque ne sont aucunement impliqués dans
les affrontements
il n'y a aucune preuve d'une
participation de la turquie au conflit
c'est juste qu'on en a pas besoin
l'armée azerbaïdjanaise est tout à fait
préparer à assurer la défense de son
peuple et de son territoire face à
l'éventuelle implication turc
le kremlin a demandé à ankara de
s'abstenir d'envenimer la situation
nous appelons tous les pays surtout nos
pays partenaires comme la turquie à
faire tout leur possible pour parvenir à
un cessez le feu et en réglement
pacifique de ce conflit
toutes sortes de déclarations sur un
soutien ou une activité militaire
quelconque ne font sans doute que mettre
de l'huile sur le feu quant aux victimes
les autorités du haut karabagh les
compte déjà en dizaines une estimation
probablement bien en deçà de la réalité
les ministères de la défense arménien et
azerbaïdjanais indique avoir infligé
plusieurs centaines de pertes humaines
dans les rangs adverses
les avancées militaires de chaque camp
sont elles aussi difficile à cerner
le haut karabagh déclare avoir repris
des villages perdus la veille quand
bakou annonce gagner du terrain les
combats quant à eux emploi tout
l'arsenal de la guerre moderne
sur ces images de rt internationale les
restes d'un drone azerbaïdjanais a battu
par l'adc arménienne ces nouveaux
affrontements dans le haut-karabagh
surpasse déjà en intensité des
échauffourées de juillet dernier et de
2016 quant au conflit du début des
années 90 il avait coûté la vie à 30
mille personnes et on en vient à la
compagne présidentielle plus que jamais
marquée par l'hostilité des deux
candidats à la maison blanche au
lendemain du premier débat télévisé
entre donald trump et joe biden et les
échanges ont été musclés entre le
président républicain et son rival
démocrate à un peu plus d'un mois du
scrutin
les organisateurs envisagent des mesures
pour maintenir l'ordre lors des
prochains débats
retour sur cette confrontation avec
mehdi escaffit c'est le caniche de
poutine
vous n'avez pas ça dans le sang vous
n'auriez jamais pu faire ça à jo tout le
monde sait que c'est un menteur
c'est difficile de la voir le dernier
mot avec ce clown il n'ya rien
d'intelligent chez vous jo en 47 ans
vous n'avez rien fait vous allez la
ferme et invectives provocation le
premier round entre donald trump et joe
biden s'est déroulée dans une atmosphère
tendue à cleveland où le débat a eu lieu
les hostilités ont d'ailleurs débuté en
dehors du plateau télévisé plus d'une
centaine de manifestants anti trump
étaient rassemblées dans cette ville de
l'ohio pour soutenir l'ancien vice
président des états unis
ce dernier qui possède toujours une
légère avance dans les sondages n'a pas
hésité à attaquer directement la
politique de l'actuel président
notamment sur sa gestion de la crise du
coc vite 19 jürg buri aux membres
whiting croyez vous un instant à ce
qu'il vous dit au vu de tous les
mensonges qu'il vous a raconté sur toute
la question du co lead
il n'a même pas encore reconnu qu'il
savait ce qui se passait qu'il savait à
quel point cela allait être dangereux en
février il ne voulait même pas 10 puis
il l'a dit officiellement il a paniqué
où il a juste regarder la bourse l'un
des deux
tout situation sanitaire environnement
ou encore affaires liées à la russie et
à l'ukraine
les deux candidats se sont livrés à des
échanges parfois houleux sur plusieurs
sujets cruciaux les tensions raciales
ont notamment été au coeur des
discussions
il dirige un jour ce pays de la façon
dont ils l'ont déjà dirigé nos banlieues
pavillonnaires n'existerait plus haut
fait nos banlieues pavillonnaires
n'existerait plus et vous verrez des
problèmes comme vous n'en avez jamais
vus il ne saurait pas reconnaître une
banlieue à moins de tomber dessus par
hasard
oh je connais les banlieues accusant les
démocrates de tricherie donald trump ne
s'est pas engagé à reconnaître les
résultats du vote en cas de défaite à
linverse de joe biden l'actuel locataire
de la maison blanche s'est contentée de
répéter que le vote par courrier
entraînerait une fraude électorale
d'ici le 3 novembre prochain deux autres
débats sont prévus des confrontations
qui devrait aider les américains à
choisir leur chef d'état pour les quatre
prochaines années et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis new york avec
caleb maupin correspondant de rtl aux
etats unis c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur
caleb maupin merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors petite phrase
attaque personnelle comment les médias
américains ont-ils jugé le premier débat
entre donald trump et joe biden
c'est un bon débat il aime les
affrontements et à l'opposition de point
de vue mais ce n'est pas la réaction qui
a suivi le débat qui a et b
qu'il s'agisse des commentateurs du
public les gens têtus d'écouté par ce
débat aucun des deux candidats n'a
montré le meilleur aspect de la mythique
il ya eu des insultes qui était en fait
assez gênante on voulait détourner le
regard
alors joe biden a réagi il y à quelques
instants en dix ans le comportement de
donald trump lors du débat est une honte
nationale
c'est donc un sentiment partagé par la
plupart des américains
je le fais et ce n'était pas que ça je
pense que de nombreux commentaires de
john bolton ont également répondu au
public en 2016
les gens ont écouté notamment le sauveur
de bas lorsque donald trump et hillary
clinton se sont affrontés découpe
personnes pensaient que c'était le
moment de télévision plus excitant qu'il
n'avait jamais vu et aujourd'hui
contraire beaucoup de personnes sont là
sont là c'est parce que ce n'est pas ce
qu'il faudrait alors à la télévision
donald trump semblait être sur la
défensive semblait presque effrayés pour
beaucoup de personnes et il a ensuite
trouvé son rythme
mais joe biden il semblait presque
fatigué il semblé manquer d'énergie il
était difficile pour lui de lever la
voile de la première demi-heure du débat
il semblait parfois trébucher que sur
ces mots donc aucun des deux candidats
n'a vraiment brillé c'était un exercice
raté alors le politologue france l'us
saintes et interrogés par bloomberg 8
parle d'un grand perdant c'est
l'électeur américain est ce que
c'est le pas le sentiment qu'ils aient
partagé autour de vous est ce que l'un
des candidats a tout de même sorti un
peu son épingle du jeu veut comparer les
deux candidats il est important de
savoir que je blyton a passé la plupart
de ce débat à mettre de la distance
entre lui et les démocrates en général
une partie importante des démocrates et
du peuple américain veulent une
couverture universelle de santé à un
système de santé fonctionnelles
je vous donne son est écartée en lisant
je suis le parti démocrate est en
expliquant qu'il n'était pas en faveur
d'une telle option
donald trump lui n'a même pas réfuter
des liens avec l'organisation d'extrême
droite américaine l'épreuve boys dix ans
il a simplement dit qu'il devait rester
en retrait et restée près donc donald
trump a semblé être beaucoup plus
sympathique envers sa base électorale
pour la droite de la politique
américaine que joe biden pour la gauche
je battais utilise les mots de la gauche
mais il s'écarte de bernie sanders était
politique vraiment de gauche
alors que donald trump n'est pas prêt à
faire la même chose avec les partis les
plus peuplés parti le plus extrême de
son mouvement alors sur les sujets de
fond telles que le coronavirus la
couverture santé vous l'évoquez à
l'instant le racisme les violences est
ce que vous avez senti les candidats
porter un vrai progrès programme être
clair avec leur cap où les électeurs
attendent encore des précisions
aucun des deux candidats n'a vraiment
présenté de programme
ils ont évoqué lance policières et les
manifestations
et de notre peuple a fait qu'affirmer
qu'il avait beaucoup de soutien policier
alors que joe biden avait pas vraiment
de réponse à donner
donald trump s'est efforcé de se
présenter comme un candidat propolis et
joe biden lui a essayé de rester de ne
pas trop s'engager il a demandé plus de
raison certaines des réactions de joe
biden semble se prêter tout
particulièrement à une deuxième vie sur
internet par exemple lorsqu'il a dit à
donald trump de se taire ce qu'il y
avait de très intéressant c'est que joe
biden a fait preuve et peut-être d'un
peu de naïveté
certains propos de donald trump semblait
est raciste et joe biden a dit aucun
autre président des états unis n'ont
jamais dit quelque chose de semblable
et pourtant nous avons eu des présidents
nous le savons bien esclavagisme nous
avons eu des présidents un très proche
du cucs cannes donc dire qu'aucun autre
président n'aurait tenu ce genre de
propos
c'est assez aberrant cela joue dans
cette idée d'un candidat un peu naïf qui
veut faire des états unis un pays plus
gentil plus aimable il veut se
débarrasser des aspects les plus
cruelles du pays que beaucoup associent
à donald trump
alors avant le débat donald trump avait
visé un les capacités intellectuelles de
son opposant joe biden at il réussi à
montrer le contraire
et c'est bien plus cohérent dans ses
propos que beaucoup ne s'y attendait il
a trébuché ici et là mais en tout cas
son message était clair les capacités
intellectuelles de joe biden sont
prouvées mais son niveau d'énergie
semblait très bas donald trump et le
qualifie de joe l'endormi effectivement
il avait l'air très passif mais en tout
cas il avait l'air tout à fait capables
de réfléchir clairement et de réagir aux
arguments de l'opposition même s'il
avait l'air un peu un peu vieux est un
peu fatigué alors pour conclure en
quelques mots caleb maupin pour les
prochaines échéances les candidats
ont-ils intérêt à revoir leur stratégie
ou les attaques personnelles et bien un
risque encore de se poursuivre jusqu'au
3 novembre et deux candidats ainsi que
leurs équipes de campagne voulant se
remettre à travailler sur leur stratégie
parce que la réaction du public est
extrêmement négatif donc les deux
candidats font sans doute essayer de
restructurer leur stratégie leur image à
la télévision afin de se rendre plus
séducteur plus séduisant pour les
électeurs qui vont déterminer le
résultat de l'élection
un grand merci caleb maupin pour votre
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
correspondant de rp aux états unis et
dans quelques instants nous ferons un
point sur la situation sanitaire en
france et dans les hôpitaux à la veille
d'un nouveau point hebdomadaire
d'olivier véran et d'improbables tour de
vis puis nous débattrons sur la
situation des étrangers en france gérald
darmanin demande aux préfets de
reconduire systématiquement ce
menaçant l'ordre public à rester avec
nous sur rt france a tout de suite
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française et c'était après les
attentats du 11 septembre
et quand on vient vous voir et qu'on
vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que c'est fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça il m'a l'air
mais quel est le rapport avec la radical
à sion mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
nous permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et la faune karl de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté qatar c'est trop fine
il ya un tournant et on recevait à vivre
mais dans une autre direction
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que pour sauver des vies
humaines en ruines la moitié de la
planète
jamais on a fait simple jamais plaint
d'une décision invraisemblable pour vous
ça dépend telles valeurs on attribuait
la mort la vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie en a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un départ n'aura
un débat éthique
qu'est ce qu'une entreprise sont des
entreprises que l'on maintient sous
perfusion combien sont-elles vous savez
plein d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui sont
des entreprises zombies et y en a plein
qui vont le devenir avec les mesures
qu'on est en train de prendre ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire dès le départ c'était
être capable d'analyser les plis dans
des entreprises pour savoir lesquels
souffrait simplement du confinement ou
de du ralentissement de l'activité il
est qu'elle était déjà en état de deux
morts avancé on est en train de tuer
l'économie et vous avez une façon de
relancer l'économie qui est beaucoup
plus saine que ce qui est annoncé là et
qui évite ce genre de problème c'est de
baisser les impôts de production
laissons les impôts sur les entreprises
qui marchent et donc qui font du
résultat celles qui sont déjà zombies
elles font pas de résultat donc vous
pouvez baisser les impôts vous n'allez
pas leur donner de l'argent en fait
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
auzolle comberge vous avez découvert que
l'imagerie médicale qui était le coeur
de votre métier avait une dimension
artistique me suis aperçu que c'était
l'art qui faisait avancer la science et
la science qui faisait avancer là
l'image est belle mais mais en général
le mal qu'elle révèle il est terrifiant
au moment du coup vite quand j'ai
attrapé moi même la maladie je me suis
dit mais pourquoi j'utilise pas ma
technique de droite et de virton life a
pour mon thorax propre et pour le virus
j'ai pu suivre son évolution
comment voyez ça s'aggravait ou au
contraire comment ça c'est mac mais
comme on a découvert le coït on sait qu
on sait comment ils les commandes
voilà quelle couleur il est qu'on a
découvert le mal les mèches du mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
nous
d
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mercredi 30 septembre 2009 la fermeture
des bars et restaurants à marseille et
aix confirmée par la justice le
gouvernement lui prolonge jusqu'à la fin
de l'année le chômage partiel à 100%
pour tous les secteurs protégés
quant au maire et président de métropole
de paris lyon lille et grenoble
ils ont rendez-vous demain matin avec
jean castex pour discuter d'éventuelles
restrictions supplémentaires avant
l'intervention du ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand elle pourrait se solder
par un nouveau tour de vis face au co
vide alors qu'une nouvelle vague menace
de submerger les hôpitaux
[Musique]
une nouvelle directive gérald darmanin a
adressé le 29 septembre un courrier aux
préfets pour leur demander de reconduire
systématiquement les étrangers ayant
commis des infractions graves ou
représentant une menace grave pour
l'ordre public
un décompte du nombre de reconduites
doit lui être adressées je cite
personnellement chaque trimestre alors
faut-il systématiquement reconduire à la
frontière les étrangers menaçant l'ordre
public
comment agir quand ils sont mineurs ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
il aura fallu près de deux ans la
belgique se dote d'un gouvernement sept
partis socialistes écologistes et
libéraux sont parvenus à un accord pour
former un gouvernement disposant d'une
majorité c'est le libéral flamand
alexander de proue 44 ans qui va
succéder comme premier ministre à la
francophone sophie willemetz
la belle province voient rouge outre
atlantique montréal et québec passe en
alerte rouge pour 28 jours les autorités
ont décrété un confinement partiel il
concerne 5 millions d'habitants et entre
en vigueur dès demain
le gouvernement a demandé à ses
concitoyens de ne pas se déplacer d'une
région à l'autre sans obligation
formelle toutefois
et on commence avec la situation
sanitaire en france et les derniers
chiffres de santé publique france
l'agent s'annonce plus de 12000
nouvelles contaminations que 8,19 en 24
heures soixante quatre personnes sont
décédées à l'hôpital et 826 patients
sont actuellement en réanimation
le taux de positivité des tests se situe
lui à 7,6 pour cent inquiétudes
notamment à paris à la veille d'une
nouvelle intervention d'olivier véran la
capitale qui a dépassé certains critères
établis par le ministre de la santé et
pourrait franchir bientôt le seuil d
alerte maximale de nouvelles mesures
pourrait entrer en vigueur ces prochains
jours
et pour parler notamment de la situation
dans les hôpitaux
nous sommes avec enrique casalino chef
du service d'urgence à l'hôpital bichat
à paris professeur henrique casalino
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pour commencer
peut-être qu'en est il de la situation
aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux à paris la
situation commence à se tendre
je ne vais pas dire que nous sommes en
difficulté ce serait exagéré mais il est
évident que progressivement nous
commençons à atteindre des niveaux
d'activité qui nous font craindre que
nous ayons des difficultés à assurer
l'ensemble de nos activités nous devons
continuer dans les hôpitaux à nous
occuper des infarctus d abaisser de la
chirurgie oncologique du traitement du
cancer de toutes les activités les
l'infinité d'activité et de dimensions
différentes que peut avoir un hôpital
aujourd'hui au moins 30% de nos lits
sont occupés par des patients qui ont le
coc vide un tiers par une seule
pathologie
ça peut si ça continue mettre en
difficulté notre capacité à accueillir
les autres situations et accueillir
aussi davantage aux deux passions qu
vide
nous avons une énorme contrainte de
personnel se sont pas uniquement les lie
c'est que notre capacité à augmenter le
nombre de lits comme lors de la première
vague pourrait être réduite par des
contraintes dans la gestion de notre
personnel alors les admission en
réanimation il
dans les hôpitaux tout l'été un jour
cela veut dire quoi que les capacités
d'accueil risque d'arriver à saturation
en novembre si ça se poursuit comme ça
pour donner une image extrêmement simple
un patient qui rentrent en réanimation
il va rester en moyenne entre 3 et 4 5
semaines vous imaginez bien que la
vitesse à laquelle ça rentre est
beaucoup plus rapide que la vitesse à
laquelle ça sort donc nous risquons dans
les trois quatre semaines à venir de
nous trouver
avec un taux d'occupation de passion
covin extrêmement élevé d'avoir à
sacrifier d'autres segments d'activité
dans l'hôpital afin de dégager du
personnel pour les réorienter sur les
secteurs convives
que ce soit en réanimation aux médecines
et nous notre obligation d'assurer
toutes les missions de l'hôpital tous
les patients doivent être accueillis la
sécurité de tous les patients doit être
garantie essart c'est quelque chose qui
peut se trouver compromise dans quelques
semaines
s'ils ne nous commençons pas dès
maintenant avoir une attitude
extrêmement rigoureuse et à prévenir que
c'est aux nouvelles poussées épidémiques
un autre monde et nous nous mettons en
difficulté
alors pari du coup en zone d' alerte
maximale c'est inévitable selon vous
c'est nécessaire même rien dit il est
inévitable mais je pense que aujourd'hui
le temps de la discussion de l' échange
de je suis d'accord tu n'es pas d'accord
je pense que c'est fini
aujourd'hui nous sommes arrivés au
moment de l'action il faut toute
complaisance vis-à-vis du virus
ce serait en faveur de virus ce serait
en faveur de mettre en difficulté le
système hôte hospitalier ce serait de
mettre en danger nos aînés de mettre en
danger nos familles et ce serait en
faveur de condamner un certain nombre de
patients que s'il ne s'infecte est pas
un certain nombre de personnes qu'elle
si elle ne s'infecte est pas elle ne
déciderait pas elle n'aurait pas dû
décédé
ce sont des morts évitables que nous
devons aujourd'hui
battre pour qu'elle ne se produise pas
et au niveau des lignes en réanimation à
ce que les cliniques privées pourraient
vous apporter leur aide ce qu'elles ont
été d'ailleurs sollicité sinon pourquoi
finalement ne pas mobiliser davantage le
secteur privé le secteur privé avait été
très mobilisés lors de la première vague
épidémique et il le sera également que
nous tous nous sommes un système
hospitalier dans lequel il y à des
activités privées et publiques tous tous
la main dans la main tout le système de
soins doit répondre hospitalier de ville
le médecin généraliste comme le
spécialiste et l'hyper spécialistes dans
tous les domaines tout le système de
santé doit répondre aux besoins de la
population c'est comme ça que ça avait
été lors de la première vague
c'est comme ça que ça devra être et se
saura j'en suis convaincu s'il y avait
une nouvelle poussée épidémique
si vous me permettez je fais juste une
métaphore nous voyons dont l'horizon un
feu rouge
on ne va pas freiner juste quand on
arrivera sur le passage clouté
on doit commencer à freiner dès
maintenant c'est dès maintenant que tout
le respect toutes les rigueurs dans le
respect des mesures barrières de la
distanciation social le port du masque
sait maintenant que ce doit être fait
pour éviter que nous arrivions à une
situation critique
une dernière question concernant la
prise en charge des patients qu'aux
vives qu'elle est ce qu'elle est
meilleure aujourd'hui est ce que les
patients restent moins longtemps à
l'hôpital
oui nous avons fait des progrès nous
avons nettement améliorer nos capacités
diagnostic nous avons m - améliorer
l'identification des filets optimale
pour les patients nous avons nettement
améliorée et stratégies thérapeutiques
pour nombre de cas nous savons que nous
pouvons réduire un certain nombre de
d'évolution défavorable chez des
patients qui ont des marqueurs
biologiques ou des critères de sévérité
nous sommes dans ce sens là aujourd'hui
mieux outiller la difficulté reste
néanmoins que ça reste une maladie qu
une fois qu'elle est présente
symptomatique et qui nécessitent une
hospitalisation et les crabes
elle peut avoir des critères de sévérité
il peut être associé à une mortalité
relativement importante à l'hôpital un
tiers des patients en réanimation vont
décéder et la réanimation est une
épreuve extrême défis extrêmement
difficiles et pour les patients et ont
leur famille
je ne souhaite à personne de connaître
ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
tous être solidaires être responsable
est trop rigoureux et protéger
l'ensemble nos concitoyens ce sont nos
attitudes individuelles qui protège la
communauté merci beaucoup henrique
casalino d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes chef du
service d'urgence à l'hôpital bichat à
paris et on reste en france et c'est une
nouvelle directive du ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin a adressé le
29 septembre un courrier aux préfets
pour leur demander de reconduire
systématiquement les étrangers ayant
commis des infractions graves ou
représentant une menace grave pour
l'ordre public comme ils l'indiquent sur
twitter un décompte du nombre de
reconduites doit lui être adressées je
cite personnellement et chaque trimestre
alors faut-il systématiquement
reconduire à la frontière les étrangers
menaçant l'ordre public que faire
lorsqu'ils sont mineurs c'est l'objet de
notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
pierre henry président de l'association
france fraternité bonsoir à vos côtés
julien haut doubs le membre du bureau
national du rassemblement national
conseiller municipal de sens bonsoir au
soir alors la question de la reconduite
messieurs systématique des étrangers
menaçant l'ordre public a été donc mis
sur la table par gérald darmanin après
l'attaqué dans les anciens locaux de
charlie hebdo cette semaine attaque
perpétrée par un jeune homme pakistanais
présenté au début comme un mineur au
début de l'enquêté
thierry henry je me tourne vers vous la
proposition de gérald darmanin quand il
s'agit d'une personne majeure
est ce qu'elle vous semblent de bon sens
c'est ce qu'elle vous choque
et concernant les mineurs est ce qu'il
faut faire une distinction écouter la
proposition de gérald armen est tout à
fait logique et tout est fait normal et
elle a déjà eu lieu auparavant
les autres ministres de l'intérieur dit
tous la même chose bien entendu qu'il
faut reconduire les personnes qui sont
et qui représente un véritable danger
pour l'ordre public mais simplement nous
sommes dans un système de droit edd rond
que c'est d'abord à la justice
évidemment de dire ce qu'est la menace
public et à partir de là si rien ne
s'oppose à l'expulsion de la personne
les vies des mots et dès lors qu'elle a
commis des faits d'une gravité telle que
son expulsion doit avoir lieu et bien
que celle ci se déroule ensuite vous
poser une autre question qui est
beaucoup plus complexe et qui concerne
les mineurs non accompagnés parce que
c'est ça que vous avez en tête et
simplement je rappelle qu'il y à une
convention internationale de protection
de
l'enfance et que dès lors que l'on est
reconnue mineurs
eh bien on rentre dans cette protection
voilà ensuite qu'il y ait des trous dans
la raquette ça c'est un autre problème
julien houle est ce que vous partagez ce
constat qu effectivement bien la justice
et existe déjà donc on laisse passer la
justice
et s'il le faut alors on renvoie les
étrangers majeurs cette fois
malheureusement la justice n'existe pas
clairement cela fait des années que nous
avons des immigrés illégaux
quelquefois délinquants quelquefois
criminels qui ne sont même pas envoyé
dans leur pays
donc c'est vrai que le petit courrier de
monsieur darmanin c'est de la
communication c'est de l'opportunisme
mais met clairement aujourd'hui quand on
voit qui est que nous avons sommes
confrontés à une vague d'immigration
massive que nous sommes confrontés à une
filière donc via ces fous mineurs isolés
parce qu'encore une fois la majorité
d'entre eux sont majeurs ça a été prouvé
par un rapport du sénat 60% d'entre eux
donc son sont majeurs et nous avons la
capacité dans notre droit de contrôler
leurs minorités notamment en exigeant
des tests osseux donc clairement il faut
avoir une politique d'extrême fermeté
fermeté d'une part protéger les français
parce qu'on l'a constaté notamment dans
plusieurs grandes villes à bordeaux que
c'est faux mineurs isolés et est
responsable de nombreuses violences
de nombreux cambriolages nombreuses
dégradations
on l'a vu évidemment avec ce terroriste
islamiste donc qui s'est fait passer
pour pour mineurs qui a été accueillie
qui a été hébergée qui a été nourri qui
a été choyé par le peuple français
et comme remerciement il nous a donné
des coups de hachoir je tiens à rappeler
quand même que ça un con et que ce coup
il est exorbitant ces cinquante mille
euros par an et par migrants c'est à
dire que ce terroriste islamiste a
bénéficié depuis son arrivée sur le
territoire national deux cent cinquante
mille euros de la poche des français
parce que c'est pas l'argent des
kron sait même pas l'argent de toutes
ces associations pro migrants si
l'argent des français c'est l'argent des
impôts donc clairement d'une part un
coût exorbitant 2 milliards d'euros
pour tous ces mineurs isolés ensuite
c'est une injustice majeure parce que
quand dans notre pays on a un français
sur trois qui n'arrivent pas à se
soigner
on a un français sur cinq qui ne mange
pas à sa faim on a quatre millions de
mal logés
c'est totalement injustifiée et
injustifiable de donner autant d'argent
à des étrangers qui encore une fois ne
mérite pas la générosité hospitalité de
la france fabien henry sur le coup a le
cou l'accueil de ces mineurs étrangers
vous rejoignez le constat de julien
houle
mais non d'abord monsieur oudoul une
technique qui est assez élaboré et le
mensonge chez lui est une seconde nature
le nombre de mineurs présents sur le
territoire national est prise en charge
par les départements s'élève aujourd'hui
à 16 milles il y as je le disais tout à
l'heure un certain nombre de trous dans
la raquette autour de la détermination
de l'âge parce que la détermination de
l'âge se fait sur la base d'un
référentiel qui date de 1930 et qui
présente des incertitudes d'environ 18
mois et cela est un véritable problème
parce qu'on peut s'interroger sur la
raison pour laquelle alors que nous
sommes en 2020 nous n'avons pas un outil
fiable de mesure de l'achat c'est le
premier élément est donc il y a aucune
raison de faire une corrélation
d'établir un lien entre immigration et
terrorisent ça c'est de la paresse
intellectuelle je voudrais rappeler à
monsieur au dol qu'il y à un nombre de
terroristes à 1
qui sont nationaux qui ne viennent pas
de l'immigration il n'y a pas de lien à
faire entre les deux c'est quelque chose
qui peut plaire aux électeurs de
monsieur odoul qui sont particulièrement
crédules mais ce n'est pas la réalité
ensuite la prise en charge
vous répondez la prise en charge des
mineurs isolés étrangers comme la prise
en charge des mineurs nationaux un coup
ce coup il est celui de l'éducation il
n'y a aucune espèce de réseaux de faire
une distinction entre les deux voilà moi
je suis favorable à ce que on remette
sur la table
toute la question de la protection de
l'enfance et que l'on est sûr notamment
à l'entrée véritablement de l'âge de la
personne ça me paraît normal dans un
dispositif pour mineurs il doit y avoir
des mineurs et non pas des machins
julien au delà
mais ensuite mais ensuite c'est beaucoup
trop simple de sortir un certain nombre
de chiffres
et puis le de balancer à la figure des
auditeurs la situation de précarité qui
prévaut dans la société française pour
mieux stigmatiser les étrangers mais
c'est un discours assez classique julien
odoul je vous laisse répondre
julien au doute je vous laisse répondre
tout de suite avant on va regarder ce
que disait françois xavier b des amis
députés les républicains au parlement
européen il s'est exprimé sur le sujet
vendredi chez nos confrères de france
impôts de france info par dangereux
vous propose de regarder ce qu'ils
disaient vous réagissez ensuite julien
houle aujourd'hui 60% des violences
commises dans l'espace public à paris le
sont par des mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés
il y à une hypocrisie massif sur le
sujet des mineurs étrangers dans notre
pays dont tout le monde sait
parfaitement que beaucoup d'entre eux ne
sont de toute évidence pas des mineurs
et profitent en réalité de la tolérance
incroyable que nous avons à l'égard du
statut qu'ils se voient reconnaître le
gouvernement actuel est coupable d'une
faute très grave sur ce sujet là
puisqu'il ya quelques mois à travers la
loi asile et immigration
il a étendu le regroupement familial des
mineurs en permettant à ces mineurs de
faire venir toute leur famille julien où
nous le finalement vous rejoignez en ce
ce constat de françois-xavier bellamy un
passé plus tôt françois xavier mélanie
qui rejoint le constat de marine le pen
est une ration de national j'ajoute que
la droite est très mal placée pour
donner des leçons en la matière
puisqu'ils n'ont jamais rien fait pour
lutter contre l' immigration anarchique
qui n'ont jamais rien fait pour éviter
donc les trafics d'êtres humains parce
que ce qui m'interpelle mois dans le
discours de monsieur c'est finalement
vous encourager les trafiquants d'êtres
humains avec ces politiques là avec ces
incitations avec cet humanisme dévoyé
parce que l'humanité la première
humanité déjà c'est de choyer en tout
cas c'est le soigner c'est de s'occuper
des siens quand dans votre famille vous
n'arrivez pas à soigner vos enfants vous
n'arrivez pas à donner à manger à vos
enfants vous n'arrivez pas les loger il
ne faut pas s'intéresser aux voisins ou
à celui du village d'à côté c'était du
bon sens rephresh charité bien ordonnée
de jean marie madeleine est en fait une
2e marié le climat sur les les proposer
aux marques sur ces mineurs en fait ces
politiques là arrache des enfants des
jeunes des adolescents quand ils sont
mineurs à leur famille dans leur pays
d'origine et la responsabilité d'un
véritable humanisme serait fait
finalement 2-2 les monnaies d'origine
qui ne sont pas des pays en guerre pour
la plupart parce que c'est la côte
d'ivoire parce que c'est des pays du
maghreb
parce que c'est le sénégal parce que
c'est ghana et cetera donc ce ne sont
pas des pays en guerre
donc pourquoi les faire venir chez nous
pourquoi les faire prendre en charge par
la collectivité nationale par les impôts
des français quand encore une fois nous
à julien candelon julien audy love
summer et autant de soucis notamment
julien houdu le on va entendre pierre
henry notamment sur sur cette question
d'encourager les trafics humains est ce
que c'est le cas selon vous ou comment
est-ce qu'on pourrait prendre en amont
le problème de la venue de ces de ses
enfants sur le territoire français ces
enfants étrangers
oui enfin monsieur odoul c'est pas parce
que vous avez une grande gueule que vous
êtes obligé en permanence de franchir le
mur les imbécilités des insanités peut
vous délivrer en permanence sur la
question des trucs sur la question du
trafic
notre dossier sur sade évidemment de va
chercher ces jeunes gens qui fuient des
situations de guerre des 2 be there
économique et qui risquent leur vie sur
la route victoire personne si la fameuse
notion de l'appel d'air qui est celle
qui est développé par le front national
et par monsieur odoul est une notion
stupide c'est notre démocratie c'est
notre système social qui évidemment peut
attirer un certain nombre de jeunes gens
qui n'ont aucun avenir dans leur pays
mais personne ne va les chercher et je
suis le premier à vouloir il veut punir
tous ceux et toutes celles qui font
commerce du trafic d'êtres humains mais
monsieur odoul ne paie pas trafic
d'êtres humains mais par contre il fait
de la question de l'immigration
un véritable business et c'est le
business
de l'aisne c'est le sens des business
dieu pour un fou de l'autre et c'est le
business ou des permanences pardon et et
et écoutez écoutez vous écouter vous
également parce que nous on vous entend
pas et ça va pas être très clair en
français qui considèrent qu'il ya trop
d'immigrés dans notre pays
ils n'en veulent plus ils n'en peuvent
plus et jure une fois de plus soignée
accueillir julien aux dons le compte
tenu des déficits contenus de nos
comptes sociaux
julien roudoule c'est vrai qu'à porter
assistance à ces mineurs c'est aussi
l'adn de la france pays des droits de
l'homme finalement qu'est ce qui vous
pose problème au fond mais encore une
fois nous sommes un pays d'asile
mais v sauf que le problème c'était
demande d'asile la demande d'asile a été
dévoyé la demande d'asile c'est quoi
c'est quelqu'un vous persécutent les en
politique m'a personnellement dans son
pays pour des raisons religieuses pour
des raisons de philosophie pour des
raisons d' orientation sexuelle c'est
asia bibi au pakistan et dont outre ces
salman rushdie c'est ça la zil ce ne
sont pas des populations entières qui
encore une fois ne viennent pas de pays
en guerre
ce sont des filières d'immigration
économique qui profite de notre
générosité qui profitent de la
générosité de l'état français et encore
une fois je le dis c'est les français
qui payent et compte tenu aujourd'hui de
la situation économique qui est un autre
9 millions de pauvres 6 millions de
chômeurs 4 millions de mal-logés un
français sur trois qui ne se soigne pas
nous avons un système hospitalier dont
la crise du coronavirus a montré qu'il
était en lambeaux
nous avons encore une fois un système
hospitalier qui manquent de lits de
réanimation et au contraire nous avons
un gouvernement qui préfère ouvrir 4000
places pour les demandeurs d'asile alors
qu'il faudrait plutôt 4000 lits de
rennes images et henri-jean clairement
nous ne pouvons pas accueillir et le bon
sens c'est plutôt de s'occuper des
français qui souffrent avant de
s'occuper de la terre entière
pierrot rire on vous laisse le mot de la
fin il ne reste que quelques secondes
pour conclure oui ben vous savez vous
avez
nous sommes en pleine période de co vide
et il suffit de demander aux personnes
qui hélas ont fait un passage par
l'hôpital les clients s'en sortir qui
donc les a soignés dans les hôpitaux
ce sont ces personnes que sont en train
de fustiger le rassemblement national et
monsieur odoul l'immigration c'est aussi
lorsque celle ci lit et tout est fait
maîtrisez donc aucun amalgame à feurs il
y a de la fermeté à avoir dès lors que
les règles sont enfreintes qu'elles sont
qu'il y à des fraudes mais évidemment je
rejette tous les discours de haine et
d'instrumentaliser sexualité souris
grâce à des fins électorales telles que
le boeuf le fait monsieur merci en tout
cas à tous les deux d'avoir accepté le
jeu du débat merci à vous bien henry je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association france fraternité à verser
avoue julien houde où le membre du
bureau national du rassemblement
national
conseiller municipal de sens est resté
avec nous sur rt france dans quelques
instants direction la belgique 16 mois
après des élections et plusieurs échecs
le pays a réussi à former un
gouvernement composé d'une coalition de
cette partie puis nous traverseront
l'atlantique où l'augmentation des
quatre coville oblige montréal et québec
à se confiner partiellement a tout de
suite sur rt france
[Musique]
hu
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
notre point fort pas notre point faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
certain chohada et tout le monde discute
est finalement que mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois vous voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus c'est pas s'ils savent que c'est
leur fin ils se préparent le seul
langage qu'ils connaissaient la violence
il ne va pas être violent mais on va
rester
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la veille d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche plus
extrêmes
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france si vous
nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
c'est une interminable attente qui a
pris fin aujourd'hui en belgique après
seize mois d'indécision un nouveau
gouvernement va entrer en fonction avec
à sa tête l'ancien ministre des finances
le libéral flamand alexander d'écrou les
explications de quentin mauclair le
point presse presque terminée c'est une
manière assez cocasse que paul magnette
leader du parti socialiste annonce qu
alexander de croo sera le nouveau
premier ministre belge
un peu d'humour pour marquer la fin
d'une crise politique de 493 jours
alexander de croo ancien vice président
du conseil et ministre des finances dans
le gouvernement précédent est membre du
parti libéral flamand open vld
il dispose désormais de quelques heures
pour constituer son équipe sous le sigle
de la coalition dite vivaldi cet esprit
là
cet esprit d'être travailler ensemble
cet esprit de trouver des solutions
c'est ce que j'ai ressenti autour de la
table aussi dans cet accord qu'on a
conclu avec les sept partis
on va avoir besoin de tout le monde pour
de nouveau faire fonctionner notre
société pour faire fonctionner notre
pays de nouveau pour répondre aux
attentes que la population a de nous
l'accorder cette partie est baptisée
viva dit en référence aux quatre saisons
du compositeur elles correspondent aux
couleurs des quatre familles politiques
présentes dans cette alliance au sein de
cette coalition on retrouve les deux
partis socialiste le ps et le sp.a les
deux partis libéraux
l'open vld et le mouvement réformateur
les écologistes des partis écolo et
groen
et enfin les chrétiens-démocrates du
cd&v ensemble il dispose de la majorité
au parlement fédéral
avec 87 des 150 sièges je ne pourrais
pas vous dire à quel point ce matin
c'est un profond soulagement
c'est un moment que nous attendons tous
depuis
seize mois maintenant 16 mois d'une
crise trop profonde
trop longue qui a profondément abîmée la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans la
politique cela ne devrait être qu'une
formalité mais le parlement doit
accorder sa confiance au gouvernement
nommé par le nouveau premier ministre
l'ensemble des ministres prêteront
serment ce jeudi matin le vote de
confiance du parlement pourrait quant à
lui avoir lieu samedi
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
bertin mampaka sénateur belge bertin
mampaka merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors seize mois depuis
les législatifs pour former un
gouvernement avant de nous parler de
cette nouvelle formation
est-ce que vous pouvez revenir sur les
raisons qui expliquent un blocage aussi
long mais vous êtes sans ignorer que les
dernières élections qui ont eu lieu ont
permis aux extrêmes aux extrémistes
flamands étaient pas raciste de glace
bay dame de monter et dans le sud du
pays
dans la partie francophone parti
communiste autrement dit le ptb de faire
de même ce qui a un peu réduit la marge
formation de gouvernement par rapport
aux partis traditionnels ça a pris du
temps parce que il ya plusieurs enjeux
sous la table notamment des réformes
institutionnelles en sommes à la 6e une
septième se profile à l'horizon
et ça ce sont les premières
revendications des gens du nord en tout
cas même si les parties du sud c'est
annie francophones estiment aussi que
ces réformes devraient être dans les 2
sens c'est-à-dire refédéralisation une
compétence qui ont été régionalisée
communautariser mais qui ne fonctionne
pas bien et la crise' qu'ovide nous a
permis de découvrir que nous avons une
offre ministre de la santé dans un pays
de 11 millions d'habitants
tout ça ce sont des enjeux qui font que
la l'accord n'a pas été facile à trouver
sans compter les questions d'éthique et
la relève
danse économique elle même qui devient
pressante et entraînent beaucoup
d'autres hors jeu alors des semaines de
discussions sept partis politiques pour
former une coalition majoritaire
cette coalition baptisée vivaldi est ce
que cela sera facile de gouverner avec
autant de disparités de point de vue
c'est pour ça que le fameux compromis à
la belge que vous connaissez c'est une
tradition à ce nous bien entendu et que
l'accord de majorité qui a été scellé
par les négociateurs fixe les balises
dans lesquels on est supposé n'est pas
avoir des surprises important donc les
points qui fâchent ont fait l'objet
d'une dune d'une négociation âpre dans
les détails d'ailleurs quelles sont
celles qui fâchent justement quels sont
tous points qui fin justement j'ai par
exemple pour ceux que nous concerne nous
le parti refera le mouvement réformateur
ce sont les poids relatif à une taxation
un jeu une rage ce que vous avez empêché
ou en france la rage taxatoire donc nous
avons réussi à maintenir quand même à
éviter l'augmentation des divers taxes
sur le travailleur
nous avons réussi sur un sujet qui vous
occupe beaucoup sur la retraite à 67 ans
que nous avons déjà obtenu un départ à
revenir déçu alors que vous en discute
encore beaucoup c'était des acquis de
gouvernement de charles michel comme
vous ne l'ignorez pas qui est présent
lors du conseil de l'europe et des
sources où il met donc pour nous l'enjeu
est non seulement de maintenir les
acquis tels gouvernement que nous avons
aux coups portés
car notre système avait du cac perd milk
partis le parti réformateur puisse avoir
sept ministres sont 14 donc n'est pas
défaire ce qui a été fait ça n'a pas été
facile
et tout ça en concertation avec les
sociaux chrétiens les écologistes dont
nous épousons beaucoup de préoccupations
en matière de des enjeux climatiques et
énergétiques et tout ça donc ce sont
deux points de vue qui concerne non
seulement la réforme nationale comme tel
la manière de gouverner la belgique mais
aussi les enjeux qui sont sur la table
chez vous et dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui alors le parti nationaliste
flamand vous en parliez tout à l'heure
qui a obtenu la plus grande part des
voix en 2019 avec 16% ne fait donc pas
partie de la nouvelle coalition
gouvernementale il en va de même pour le
vlaams belang parti de la droite
radicale ayant obtenu 12 % des voix lors
des dernières élections
est ce que font ces pas cette lutte
contre la droite radicale
c'est pas le cap qui unit le
gouvernement finalement oui j'ai le
sentiment que c'est une lecture qui peut
être fait de cette façon là mais en
réalité que demandent les flamands que
des mondes donc nos concitoyens belge du
nord ils demandent une réforme
institutionnelle d'abord qu'elle nous
allons leur accorder dans des conditions
qui sont je vais dire plus sereine que
ce que bart de wever voulait mettre
précipitamment sous la table comme
condition pour son entrée dans le
gouvernement des réformes
institutionnelles en des conséquences
lourdes haute sur l'économie du pays sur
le bien-être des citoyens belges
et on l'a vu grâce aux qu'ovide ne se
font pas dans la précipitation je suis
convaincu que ce gouvernement qui va
aborder des réformes additionnelles dans
un agenda beaucoup plus serein
beaucoup plus calme nous permettra de
proposer aux belges du nord et du sud
une septième réforme parce que ça sera
la septième qui sera certainement
meilleur bien réfléchi sans comment
dirais-je des mythes et l'organisation
de la gestion du pays
comme certains ont précédé le faire
encore il ya quelques semaines
alors pour conclure peut-être un mot sur
la personne du nouveau premier ministre
alexander de coûts c'est un libéral
flamand il était vice premier ministre
et ministre des gouvernes de ministre
des finances dans le gouvernement
sortant quel regard vous portez sur ce
nouveau premier ministre
j'ai suis fascinée - je suis sexagénaire
j'ai 20 ans de vie politique active à la
mairie de bruxelles c'est un rôle dans
toutes les assemblées pratiquement à par
le parlement flamand où je n'ai pas
siéger donc je regarde avec propos de
comment disent on dirait temps beaucoup
d'attention cette nouvelle classe
politique 44 ans vous à vivre apprend à
39 ans nous avons georges lui boucher 34
ans chez nous lui même votre ami
alexander est dévenu présente partie 1
34 ans c'est une génération qui me
fascine - à titre individuel parce que
elle est inscrit dans une dynamique dans
le défi dès demain pour savoir où est-ce
que se situera l'europe avec eux
tout ce qui se passe autour de nous les
la puissance la montée des dettes et
d'achille le le le
le cavalier seul des américains est l
europe qui vient de s'ouvrir sur votre
site
donc ce sont des gens qui sont une
génération des gens qui sont vraiment à
qui j'ai fait confiance dans la
gouvernance dès demain et ça va vite
regarder et charles michel
là où ils se trouvent un accord a pu
être trouvé a dit pas ça rapidement mais
ils ont une capacité de travail capacité
de travail et les visions du monde dans
lequel nous inscrivons moi je suis très
rassuré par alexander outre le fait que
je connais bien le ps est aussi l'un des
plus anciens parlementaires
un des leviers politiques belges il a un
bon conseiller
même s'il n'avait pas devoir admettre
ses conseils mais il a un bon conseiller
une lourde expérience pour pouvoir mener
cette équipe avec succès et les
résultats que les belges attendent
n'oublions pas qu'il y a aux coudes et
menace sur le plan économique et que la
première priorité sasp est d'assurer le
bien-être de nos concitoyens dans une
europe qui est aussi en crise
merci beaucoup bertin mampaka d'avoir
répondu à nos questions nous avoir
éclairé sur la situation en belgique je
rappelle que vous êtes sénateur belge
est la suite du feuilleton sans fin du
bric site neuvième session de
pourparlers cette semaine entre londres
et bruxelles
en toile de fond l'ombre d'un divorce
dur qui refait surface après
l'approbation hier par les députés
britanniques et d'un projet de loi
controversé qui propose de revenir sur
une partie de l'accord de retrait
négocié
il y a un an par les deux parties de
quoi déclencher la colère de bruxelles
les détails en images
[Musique]
à
en
[Musique]
on
en
[Musique]
ans
la direction outre atlantique à présent
montréal et québec passe en alerte rouge
pour 28 jours les autorités ont décrété
un confinement partiel il concerne 5
millions d'habitants et entre en vigueur
dès demain elle quelques précisions tout
de suite en images
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jérôme blanchet gravel journaliste
essayiste jérôme blanchet gravel merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rtl
france alors françois legault le premier
ministre du québec parle d'une situation
critique critique à quel point on sait
pas exactement c'est un peu le
scepticisme d'ailleurs la population
malgré l'apparent de consensus je vous
dirais que quand même une certaine
insatisfaction qui commencent à émerger
donc jusqu'à quel point ces justifie on
ne sait pas exactement parce que de
toute façon vous le savez n'est pas
vraiment de consensus scientifique sur
les mesures à adopter du moins il y en a
parmi le gouvernement le gouvernement
évidemment des mesures prennent est
l'autre est clair ce city jusqu'à quel
point c'est pas moi qui pourrait vous
répondre exactement sur cette question
le tout le monde un peu son avis sur la
question la dangerosité du virus
actuellement en tout cas fermeture des
restaurants des bars des casinos des
théâtres des bibliothèques pas de
réception à domicile et le gouvernement
qui demande à ses concitoyens de ne pas
se déplacer d'une région à l'autre
ça ressemble quand même un confinement
partiel oui tout à fait c'est un
confinement mais on veut pas
nécessairement l'avouer mais on en en
quoi par exemple le mot confinement de
confinement je me rappelle avoir attendu
mais on y est c'est à peu près la même
chose le premier ministre le bo a même
évoqué la possibilité la perspective
d'une quatrième vague donc ce qu'est ce
que ça veut dire c'est que on en a pas
pour longtemps c'est cette crise leur
durée est de damas se prépare à ce que
la crise dure très longtemps donc quand
je vous parlais satisfaction grands
centres d'examen les gestes de plus en
plus inquiets par rapport aux dommages
collatéraux un dommages collatéraux
économique dommages collatéraux et
psychologique
les psychologues le diront peut-être que
l'état général la population sur le plan
de la santé mentale à ses potes
vaud comme vous pourriez exil en france
ce qui est déplorable d'une certaine
façon c'est également d'avis le
gouvernement legault a adopté la
philosophie du risque zéro
donc on est un peu dans une utopie
sanitaires c'est à dire vrai sport oui
parce qu'en fait le finalement la
situation dans les hôpitaux par exemple
est-ce qu'ils sont saturés aujourd'hui
apparemment non les exécutions sont pas
encore saturés et c'est à dire qu'il
s'agit encore à ce que je pourrais
plusieurs interprétations si on n'est
pas encore tout à fait dans la deuxième
vague fins et on essaie de la paix
menées certains disent qu'on l'a on est
on est dedans j'ai parlé à des médecins
voient comme journaliste en carrière qui
me disait que on n'était pas tout à fait
encore dans la deuxième vague
donc comme je vous dis le consensus
scientifique
il y en a pas exactement vous le savez
en france vous avez eu des débats aussi
les médecins sont pas consensuels
donc est ce qu'on parle d'un convoi y
arriver à cette deuxième vague là parce
que je veux lâche marc lecerf les bars
les restos rappelé chez les jeunes en
particulier que se sentent moins
vulnérable mais c'est pas moi qui va
vous parler de qui va vous dire sur un
banc dogmatique que on est absolument la
deuxième en tout cas montréal et québec
passe au plus haut niveau d' alerte
pendant 28 jours
est ce qu'il ya des risques ce que cela
s'étende à d'autres provinces selon vous
il faut savoir au canada c'est que la
santé c'est un domaine de compétence
provinciale donc chaque corps s en sont
vos appareils de mesure donc c'est pas
le la réaction est pas uniforme au
canada donc est ce que c'est les
contagions peut s'étendre aux autres
provinces c'est dur à dire
je pense que toutes les provinces si
jamais d'ailleurs les voyages entre les
provinces sont fortement déconseillés
l'autre
donc ce sera à voir l'ontario se
préparent également 12e la province
canadienne la plus populeuse ce cap a
elle aussi à faire face à un deuxième
bague apparemment plus
monstrueuse que la première donc tout ça
reste à voir dans les prochains jours
alors les milieux de la restauration ou
encore les milieux culturels estime
qu'il sortait lentement la tête de l'eau
les conséquences économiques sur qu'elle
vaut qu'est-ce qu'elles vont être après
ces nouvelles mesures de restriction
bonne question le statut de lui et je
vous parle du tapis sanitaire justin
trudeau lui semble plutôt dans l'utopie
économique et multiplient les aides
financières aux particuliers aux
établissements privés au commerce
quel sera l'état du canada
économiquement parlant après la crise
c'est une bonne question ce qui est ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'on le voit c'est
tangible on voit de plus en plus de
commerces fermés on le voyait des
panneaux clic est donc dans la rue c'est
quelque chose de tangible elie centre
ville sont désertées des gens à fond du
télétravail
donc le centre-ville de montréal par
exemple ça va extrêmement mal ça va
extrêmement mal le centre-ville de
montréal c'est une catastrophe donc
jusqu'à quel point les gouvernements
vont pouvoir imposer ce genre de mesures
là évidemment qui dit pacte économique
des impacts psychologiques commises au
début c'est sarah toujours ensemble
merci beaucoup jérôme blanchet gravel
d'avoir répondu à nos questions de nous
avoir éclairé sur la situation à
montréal et au québec je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et essayiste et
dans le reste de l'actualité un groupe
partenaire de twitter at il violé les
règles du réseau social en matière de
surveillance de ses utilisateurs
et bien non selon twitter mais la
question se pose après que la plateforme
a estimé que son partenaire et qui
fournit des indications à la police sur
les sites de manifestation ne violait
aucune de ces règles en la matière
explications estelle farges
qu'est ce qui constitue ou non de la
surveillance et le débat qu'a provoqué
twitter après avoir pris la défense de
datamine
or l'une de ses entreprises partenaires
vous n'en avez sans doute jamais entendu
parler mais data mineurs collabore avec
des centaines d'entreprises dans 70 pays
à travers le monde
son job informer ses clients des
événements considérés à risque
la plate forme d'intelligence
artificielle en temps réel de data
minder détecte les signaux les plus
précoces d'événements à fort impact et
les risques émergents à partir de
données publiques selon un article du
wall street journal ces derniers mois
date à mineurs a transmis à la police
américaine et à des organismes
gouvernementaux des alertes issus de
tweets concernant par exemple des appels
à manifester ou encore les ruches que
les manifestants envisageaient de
bloquer une alerte a été envoyée tôt le
13 juin au personnel du département de
la défense
les informant qu'une manifestation était
programmée dans l'après midi à une
adresse non loin du parc olympique du
centenaire
atlanta en réaction à des tirs de police
sur un homme noir nommé richard brooks
la du précédente et ce n'est pas tout
phr data mineur aurait aussi fourni des
informations sur de futures
manifestations prévues aux états unis
dans le cadre du mouvement black live
matters c'est en tout cas ce que révèle
en arctique deux ils interceptent daté
du 9 juillet dernier
selon des documents internes consultés
par interstate data myners a non
seulement méticuleusement tracé des
manifestations en cours mais a aussi
enregistré de façon exhaustive de futurs
rassemblements contre les violences
policières dans des villes de tout le
pays pour aider son personnel a organisé
ses efforts de surveillance y compris
l'heure prévue des événements et le lieu
de départ dans ces villes alors simple
veille des réseaux sociaux ou
surveillance de son côté twitter a
indiqué avoir mené un audit sur les
services proposés par data mineurs
conclusion la firme ne viole aucune des
raies
le du réseau social en matière de
surveillance en d'autres termes
circulez il n'ya rien à voir et c'est la
fin de cette émission on se retrouve
dans quelques minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité rester avec nous
sur rt france
comment on devient jean louis etienne
parce que vous êtes un héros pour plein
d'enfants je rêvais de faire des
expéditions se trouve savoir ce que
c'était et l'arrivée au pôle nord
quelques années après je me souviens
très bien du moment où je me suis dit
mais ça ça va être mal ce parcours là
vous a placé dans la bataille écologique
le réchauffement climatique est une
réalité quand on voit bien en 37 quand
on a un degré de plus de 38 en médecine
à une fabrique une petite fièvre gouffre
quelque chose la planète l année là
aujourd'hui chacun dans ses activités
impact la nature impacte notre les
questions environnementales
le risque c'est évident